what's up guys I'm Alessia Cara and I'm
here to talk about my album the pains of
growing with some really beautiful
puppies he hates me already oh my gosh
oh my goodness they don't know what to
do with themselves this one loves me
this one loves me
hello who has been your best and take me
to dinner first
I met Oprah at a party hi I'm an Oprah
at a party and it was right after I won
the Grammy and she spotted me and came
up to me and was like hi bosz new artist
and I freaked freaked
Pete did he gave me like a weird
half-assed handshake once what like
before I was anybody so ah he's
attacking me I think he's a do you watch
YouTube if so what would you recommend I
do watch YouTube jenna Marbles and
Julianne sulamita are amazing they have
a really cool podcast called J and J
podcast bellifiore is really great cuz
she does these like murder mystery
segments on her channel that's amazing
and any type of black head popping video
how do you get your curls to look so
nice do you have any product you could
recommend
I think the key first of all it's a
curly hair or to getting it less frizzy
is drying your hair with a cotton
t-shirt instead of a towel a cotton
t-shirt just keeps all the moisture in
and don't make hair frizzy so that's
step number one and then you can use
some sort of sea salt spray I use a
coconut oil spray I think it's my
Moroccan oil I'm not quite sure I'll use
that and a diffuser diffuser is key it's
a little attachment that goes on the end
of your blow-dryer what was it like
performing and hanging out with Taylor
Swift
it was a man she's so sweet and really
really nice and made me feel so
comfortable and my whole team and family
feel incredibly comfortable so that was
really fun
hi oh my god
s marry collab with on the Hedgehog
Mendes Justin Bieber Joe okay well I
can't marry down there but I can't ask
Justin Bieber well no Justin Bieber's
already married so then maybe collab
with Justin Bieber
I can't f Shawn there I'm talking later
as if this is gonna happen I won't marry
both John Mayer and Shawn Mendes and
we'll have a nice little family
relationship nice little polygamy which
artist inspired you growing up Amy
Winehouse Lauryn Hill Shania Twain
Erykah Badu's pink house Fame affected
your personal relationships I don't know
I think for the most part they've been
the same I think maybe the only
difference is that some people who I
didn't really know before or like some
random family members that I didn't
really talk to before I have like
appeared but I think that's normal you
know and people even though you don't
talk to people for a while they're still
proud of you so I don't know I think it
makes people treat you a little bit
differently which is strange like I've
seen some people from school now that
like act like they've never known me and
they're like oh weird around me but
that's a little bit weird but for the
most part I don't know I think I've
stayed the same so the people around you
kind of stay the same - what does your
favorite / least favorite song to
perform and why I still love performing
here because it's fun and then my least
favorite is probably wild things cuz I'm
just screaming the entire time and I'm
sorry I just recently heard the studio
version for the first time in a long
time and I just realized I'm screaming
the entire time so I'm sorry for yelling
at all of you guys in that song you seem
so down-to-earth and humble what are the
things that keep you grounded
thank you um those things that keep me
grounded are probably my morals and
values I value you know the idea of
family and
the idea I just value being grounded I
value being a nice human being to other
people and I have a really great family
and great people around me that always
keep me you know down-to-earth so which
song on the album was the hardest to
write and the easiest the hardest ones
are right I don't know I don't usually
keep the songs that are hard to write to
be honest but the easiest was out of
love it just came out very quickly what
are your thoughts on Brendon Urie
oh I'm panic at the disco love them love
them so much I think he's such an
incredible performer and I think they're
amazing I saw him at the AMAs and they
were like this thick what's your
favorite Taylor Swift song oh ooh
hey Stephen Kleene speak now how do you
feel about pineapples on pizza
I don't mind it I'm neither I'm neither
here nor there with it I don't mind them
if they're on there but I don't think
it's necessary I'm not gonna order a
pineapple visa but I will eat one if
it's there are you trying to untie my no
no how do you deal with the hate from
your haters I unleash puppies on them so
okay guys that was my interview with a
bunch of these beautiful puppies goes
into my album the pains of growing if
you haven't already he's he's a big fan
or she he is a big fan and all of these
lovely sweet puppies are adoptable from
North Shore Animal League America
they're so sweet and cute and you should
take one home because they need a home
and I wish I could take them all but I
can't so you should this is very wet
[Music]